alright I'm Pat Floyd executive director
of the Port Authority I'm joined by my
colleagues Tom Bosco who's director of
aviation for the Port Authority Lisa
skully who's the general manager of
LaGuardia Airport and Tom Belfiore who's
the chief security officer of the Port
Authority also Joel be joined by Gail
Grimm and who's the senior vice
president for Delta Airlines this
morning at LaGuardia Airport about 11:05
a.m. flight 1068 from Atlanta to
LaGuardia veered off runway 13 it was
approaching from the northwest the plane
was landing the runways about 7,000 feet
approximately 45 to 5,000 feet down the
runway the aircraft veered to the left
it never made contact with the water the
aircraft was carrying 127 passengers and
five crew members happily there are only
minor injuries that have been reported
at this point we believe two passengers
have been transported to hospitals that
number may change the emergency response
why the airport rescue and firefighting
which is a division of the Port
Authority police was exemplary for ARF
trucks responded plus a stayer truck of
14 ARF airport rescue and fire fighters
in total Port Authority aviation staff
at the airport had 50 people on the
airfield
ARF response was in in minutes the Port
Authority police and ARF respond trained
for this repeatedly during the last
three weeks there were two ARF trills
here at LaGuardia for exactly this
circumstance last thing our report is
that we expect to open the other runway
4/22 at approximately 2:00 p.m. some
flights have been diverted to Newark and
to and to other airports as Ron
mentioned at the beginning of this
conference the NTSB is is on on the way
to LaGuardia will be cooperating with
them closely as with Delta we're not
going to speculate or comment on the
causes of today's incident with that
I'll turn it over to Gail grim it from
Delta Airlines thank you
this morning upon landing Delta flight
1086 from Atlanta LaGuardia exited
runway 13 the md-88
aircraft was carrying 127 customers and
five crew members customers were deplane
safely and moved to the terminals on
buses they have subsequently been
reunited with their families and are in
the midst of going back home or into the
city we are working cooperatively with
the Port Authority the NTSB and all
officials during the course of this
investigation the safety of our
passengers and our crews is Delta's
number-one priority I want to thank the
extraordinary efforts of the Port
Authority are the PA PD for their quick
response in this situation and I also
want to express Delta sincere
appreciation to our crews for their
professional and quick response to help
keep our passengers safe and get them to
the terminal safely thank you we'll take
we'll take a few questions as I
mentioned before given the fact that the
NTSB is on the way we're not going to
comment on causes and we'll leave that
to the NTSB Pat Doan a good question Pat
shortly before the incident of
approximately 11:05 two planes landed
and reported quote good braking action
on the runways the runway this
particular runway had been plowed
shortly before the incident and the
pilots on other planes reported good
braking action yes yes
i-i think the pilot did everything he
could to slow the aircraft down
obviously the pilot and the co-pilot
good efforts were reflected in the fact
that there were only minor injuries yes
yeah III think what you're referring to
is what's called a mass which is a FAA
required area at the end of each runway
at here at LaGuardia which slows
aircrafts down if they overshoot as I
mentioned approximately 4,500 to 5,000
feet down the runway the plane veered to
the left so we did not make contact with
the MS yes sure the Port Authority is
responsible for plowing and maintaining
the the runways in a clean operable
condition
the FAA decides which runways are are
used which approach planes and pilots
will use and it's up to pilots to accept
the designation of the of the FAA yes
sir
okay with respect to passengers the
chutes as we understand did not deploy
the airport rescue and firefighting
division of the Port Authority police
was on scene as I mentioned there were
14 are firefighters on scene you could
see images of those are staff members on
the wings helping passengers to plane
and the passengers deplaned were bused
to a terminal here at LaGuardia yes
fuel spill there was a minor fuel spill
the fuel for a time was leaking out at a
rate of about a gallon a minute the fuel
leak was was stopped the New York State
Department of Environmental Conservation
is is on-scene Port Authority ARF the
airport rescue and firefighting crews
applied the foam and the situation's
under control
obviously I'd also note there was a
significant presence by the fire
department of the city in New York and
we thank them for their response yes
not non minor minor injuries yes minor
injuries
it was like level 5 we were at level 5
staffing full staffing today and with
snow condition 5 yes the plane did not
make contact with the water that was
happily that was never a risk today IIIi
don't know I'd be speculating tie-dye
yeah well he was on a Burma or an
embankment but beyond that I'm not going
to speculate yes sir
minutes yes yes sir no that's not what I
said
two pilots who landed in the minutes
before reported quote with breaking
action
I'm sorry I just didn't hear the I
didn't hear the question yeah sure
so
well the decision to allow planes to
land the decision which runway is used
and which approach is used is up to the
FAA obviously the Port Authority
consults closely we had the right our
staff on here at LaGuardia today given
the conditions they responded literally
within a minute and the runway that
runway had been plowed literally month
minutes before and other pilots had
reported good braking action ultimately
obviously the pilots decision to land
last question yes
I'm not going to address any of those
questions I think those are
appropriately directed to the NTSB once
they've commenced and finished their
investigation thank you